- Like, I picked the right
person at the right time.
You wouldn't know what to me two days ago.
'Cause I got high, and I was
just too all over the place.
- [Interviewer] All right, Jennifer.
- [Jennifer] Yeah?
- [Interviewer] Jennifer,
where'd you grow up? Where
you from? Originally.
- [Jennifer] Wisconsin. Appleberry farm.
- [Interviewer] What part of Wisconsin?
- [Jennifer] Just below
Madison, Wisconsin.
I actually grew up,
and up in Portage.
With my, my regular mom,
and dad were up there.
And at age five,
my, my mom,
my mom divorced it.
Like, three.
I've had a really treacherous childhood.
But, at, at five she dumped
me off at foster fare family.
At, on a dairy farm,
which I stayed 'till 11.
- [Interviewer] Is it, Is
that the foster family?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What, what do
you think your mom did that?
- 'Cause she, 'cause she
couldn't handle a family.
My sister, my two sisters went to my dad's
in, in Portage.
And she went, and found some.
And she joined the military,
and went to Germany,
married my stepfather.
They couldn't both be in.
Otherwise it'd be separated.
So, she decide to get out, and follow him.
Get jobs at different med,
VA hospitals, and stuff.
While they were going everywhere.
Which I've been a few places
with them here, and there.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood
with the foster family?
- It's pretty good.
But I had a really,
ADHD, and a whole bunch of stuff I had.
I was a girl inside, and,
and I was starting to be bullied.
Calling a whole bunch of names,
and then I finally became the bully.
And, it was problem, problem, problem.
Until 11 where my foster family
couldn't take care of me.
I got put in the different
institutions after another.
With a couple of breaks
with my stepfather,
and mom trying to take me.
But, I was too much for them.
I mean, I've been to Fort Knox,
and Ohio, and Hawaii, and
stuff like that in Texas.
But, I, on my 18th birthday,
right before 18, I turned,
I got a graduated GED in
that last institution.
And then on 18,
on my 18th birthday,
they couldn't take me
anymore at the institution.
So, they got my sister in Ohio,
and her husband to accept me.
So they sent me there on
my 18th birthday in 86.
It's, it's, you know
And then, there was a lot
of drugs, and alcohol.
Alcohol first.
- [Interviewer] When, when
did drugs, and alcohol
come into the picture for you?
- Well, alcohol has been
in my life all along.
My dad was alcoholic.
There was quite a few times.
And when I was young,
He gave it to my mom,
mom gave it to me, everything.
Wisconsin was,
It, he could even drink
in the bars with your,
with your family as long as it,
'cause the real law was weren't.
The bar's weren't responsible.
If anything happened in
the bar with the child,
or whatever. If they're
drinking, it was on them.
On now it's changed.
Because of all the
drunk driving accidents.
You know.
So, at 18 and 86,
I really have, went into alcohol.
In 89 I died on it in Hawaii.
Drinking Bach every day.
And I stopped.
And that cocaine left Hawaii.
All in abrupt came here.
It was heroin, crack speed, everything.
And acid, and a whole bunch of stuff,
and got busted for LSD in 91.
And then I, I,
I haven't been in trouble
with the law since.
- [Interviewer] So, you today,
you're living in the tenderloin?
- I live right on the edge of,
of, the,
I live over on Mason Street.
I shouldn't say that.
I live over,
you know, near Union Square.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
But it's right at, a block away from hell.
Right in bread, a block
away from Crackville,
and all that stuff.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Are you living on the street or you...
- No. I got a, I got a apartment.
- [Interviewer] Okay. How
do you support yourself?
How do you make money?
- Disability.
- [Interviewer] And,
do you have any contact
with your family, still?
(Jennifer speaking indistinctly)
Mom in 2005.
Dad in 2007.
My mom left that
inheritance for my sisters,
and I, it came through
in 2007, and since then.
Because I'm legally blind.
My sister found a way to
get the, the survivor benefits
for me, not my stepfather.
And, ever since then, I've had an extra,
a little bit
to help me.
And then, where I live now,
I pay 50% of my income.
- [Interviewer] What was
been the hardest part
of being trans for you?
- [Jennifer] Well, I
haven't had as much problems
as most girls I've heard about, you know,
getting harassed, because of it.
Probably, because I
appear myself streetwise.
And I, I will beat somebody up if they,
you know, screw on me.
I, I bring that parts with me.
Because, I don't want
somebody punking me out.
'Cause then I'll have to get into it,
and gets me out a lot of stuff.
I've been in a lot of
projects to get crack, and,
seen a lot of stuff.
I don't, you know, I got
extreme PTSD, some stuffs.
I've seen some horror stuff
that nobody needs to see.
- [Interviewer] What, What's
the worst thing you've seen?
- [Jennifer] I mean, I've seen pills.
I don't need to say exactly what.
But, I've seen a lot of
different variations of killing
right in front of me.
I've had guns put on my head.
And after that, that the scope me out
to see if I had to say
something, or something.
I seconds away from them killing me too.
But my hour is different, you know.
That's the way I carry myself.
And, plus, I have a higher
power that has been helping me.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your years,
living on the streets, and stuff.
- [Jennifer] Well, it's, It's
a lesson of life, you know,
you know, you don't snitch.
You don't, you don't,
you don't steal from anybody.
Everybody has that lesson about, you know,
stealing from stores, and
things that can handle it,
and stuff like that.
But, copper piping, and whatever.
That's why I stopped heroin
in the nine, early 90's.
I did it for like, a year.
And, I got to the point where
I broke at, with Mercedes FL
window for a leather jacket.
That was in the back.
That's pretty much, I think
that's the only thing I stole
from a person.
That's probably why I
got a lot of good karma.
- [Interviewer] And
crack is your drug today?
- No. It's off and on.
- [Interviewer] What,
what are your drug now?
(Jennifer laughs)
- LSD,
crack, and meth.
- [Interviewer] But you've tried them all?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Just, just the empty, and a few others,
molly, and stuff like that I haven't done.
- [Interviewer] And you,
you were born this way,
you believe, right?
It's not something that
happened to you as a kid,
or anything like that.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Interviewer] You knew,
you knew this since,
since you were a young child?
- Yeah. Kind of.
And, and I had, you know,
different signs of it.
And, I had a partner
in 91 to two,
right before 2001.
He picked me up on Polk Street
when I was hustling my ass for
whatever I could to get more.
Done a lot of that.
- [Interviewer] So, you'd
done some sex work as well?
- Yeah. And...
- [Interviewer] Is this
something you still do?
- Well, in the right, in the right,
I haven't done it for a while.
But, in the right most place, I would.
But, this guy picked me up.
He didn't ever have sex with me.
He didn't want that.
You know, he just wanted a partner.
Kind of, he was, he ended
up being a part owner
of a really famous gay bar in the city.
And I,
I could have done this
transition with him.
I don't know why I didn't.
I guess cards played the way they did.
I ended up leaving him for a woman
to try that way once.
I try to, I've made an
honest effort to go that way.
If it, you know, it, it's
a shame that I left them.
It wasn't about getting an
inheritance from, or anything.
Because, I probably do
have something there.
I just never went. I don't need it.
Because, of the way I left him.
And...
But, he took me around the world.
To like, Bali,
India.
You know, a whole bunch of
places in the sun over there.
But never had sex, and now I know why.
I mean, I was in the psych
ward when I was with her.
At one point in the same
hospital, he died in.
And...
Later she,
it's almost like she showed me on purpose
just to stab at me. Because, how,
you know.
'Cause when she, when
she found out that I,
when I first started dating her,
she found out I was going home to him,
and sleeping in the same bed.
And she was like, "You
got to move in with me."
(Jennifer speaking indistinctly)
abruptly leaving him.
And, she did a lot of...
She's, she's a really famous
person here on the lab.
Six figures at one time.
And, I never paid rent with her either.
And, yeah, it was
interesting. I learned a lot.
You know, every time I relapsed,
I had many years clean here.
Two weeks relapse, then a year of clean.
I got clean in two thou...
1994.
For four and a half years.
Ended up a Hep C.
From tatt, from tattooer.
- [Interviewer] Use your hand.
- I could have had AIDS or anything.
You know, that I found out.
That's why,
got a,
he never had sex with me.
'Cause that's what he died
from HIV complications.
He never told me.
And I probably would have never met him,
(Jennifer speaking indistinctly)
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- I have lots of friends.
But they're all in recovery.
And I don't, you know, I'm starting to.
That's what keeps him getting relapsing.
Sometimes I, you know, I used
to have a network of friends,
and sponsors that they
call me, I called them.
Now, everybody sits there
and do their own thing.
I hardly ever, ever have
anybody call me anymore.
So, it's like, that little
loneliness thing, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Are they really my friends.
And, to think that's the thing
that makes me want to
move to a different area,
to get new friends that don't have my rec,
long record of in, and out of the rooms.
'Cause a lot of my friends have
decades sober, or whatever.
And they don't get it
that I'm still alive,
and haven't gotten yet.
And they don't treat me like
a new comer, coming back.
Like, they're, the program
says you're supposed to,
and that's pretty much what
I'm thinking about right now,
you know.
Some, right now I'm having
a little off, and off again,
you know, on again.
Fun.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. What,
what's been the best time
of your life?
- I don't know. Probably,
when I was with Ben.
- [Interviewer] And what's
been the roughest time?
- Still down in the street
life. I mean, in 2015.
You asked me something about trans.
I was at the next door shelter on Polk,
and
doing sex work, and stuff.
And I,
ended up being,
getting pills stuff, and crack deal
for paying me off for five bucks.
And I went back on them the next day.
And I told him, you can't do that.
You got, Oh, you owe me.
And he's, tousled tried
to get money out of me.
And he said, "No, no, no".
And then, he started
to bust something out.
But give me a little piece.
I'm like, you know, you have
to pay for your mistake.
And then, he realized I was serious.
And then he sucker punched me in, and ran,
and he ran into a Polk,
and then got on, and
beat the hell out of him.
And I could've been killed that night.
Because, I was just in a
position where they all had guns,
and a lot of drugs, and
there was a drug corner,
and you don't do that shit.
They laughed at first.
Because, they never seen a trans like,
take out a guy like that.
And then, somebody came in,
and kicked me in the head,
and my head got a cut here,
and almost lost my eye.
And then, when I came to, I
was getting punched, and kicked
like, I was getting,
and jumped into a gang.
So, this is another lesson
of life that I knew,
knew from a gut.
You know, it's like, a street corner.
If you can walk away from this, just do.
So, I walked away bloody,
and walked up to the shelter,
and I,
and I
did the,
you know, animal stuff there.
And then, a couple of days later,
and that ended up earning me
street cred with drug dealers.
- [Interviewer] What the, what,
what advice would you give
to a young trans persons?
Considering.
- Well, to do it, do,
go with your heart,
and, and just follow yourself.
You know, where you need to go and, and,
and just make sure you have
straight around, you know.
The lessons you learn about protection
before your transition.
You gotta keep that, you know.
Because, it's like, if
you look like somebody,
you can get, you know, take
advantage of, or killed.
They'll do that.
You gotta put that energy away from you.
Because, I don't bring that towards me.
That doesn't quite come towards me.
I've hardly had anybody
try do anything again.
I've carried thousands of dollars on me,
and nobody's come at me.
'Cause, I appear like,
I don't have anything.
I just, you know.
I just don't, you know,
I just learned so many lessons
that could be here for
three, and a half hours
just telling him all things.
So, this could be a two
part if you need it.
So...
- [Interviewer] All right,
Jennifer. Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Thank you.
And, good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Okay. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.